Générique
- Alexandre Poussart:
Bonjour à tous.
Bienvenue dans "Parlement hebdo".
Nous revenons sur l'actualité de
la semaine au Parlement.
- Kathia Gilder: Cette semaine,
nous accueillons Claude Malhuret.
Vous êtes sénateur de l'Allier.
- Alexandre Poussart: Cette
semaine, le bras de fer qui
continue entre la majorité
présidentielle et les oppositions
autour de la réforme des retraites
et de la proposition de loi du
groupe LIOT.
La requête d'abrogation de la
réforme a été rejetée.
La présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale devrait déclarer
irrecevable cette mesure sur le
plan financier.
Le Sénat poursuit son travail
autour de la démission du maire de
Saint-Brevin.
Le préfet de Loire-Atlantique et
le sous-préfet de Saint-Nazaire
ont été entendus.
Il y aurait une proposition de loi
pour mieux protéger nos élus au
Sénat.
On parlera de la commission
d'enquête du Sénat sur le réseau
social chinois TikTok.
Les sénateurs tentent de faire la
lumière sur la stratégie
d'influence de Pékin.
- Kathia Gilder: D'abord, le sujet
de la semaine: les retraites.
En commission parlementaire, la
majorité a vidé le texte de LIOT
de son article clé, celui qui
visait à abroger les mesures
phares de la réforme.
- Pour: 38.
Contre: 34.
- A quatre voix près, la majorité
et Les Républicains rejettent
l'abrogation de la réforme avec
l'âge de départ à la retraite à 64
ans.
- Cette proposition de loi est
d'utilité publique.
- Tout le monde sait que jamais
cette proposition ne sera votée au
Sénat.
Tout le monde sait dans cette
salle que cette proposition est
anticonstitutionnelle.
- La gauche tente une
contre-attaque en déposant jusqu'à
3000 amendements, pour empêcher
les débats d'aller à leur terme.
Le bureau de la commission décide
de ne pas les examiner.
- Notre rôle de parlementaires ne
sert plus à grand-chose, nous le
constatons.
Donc, nous partons.
- La NUPES claque la porte.
La proposition de loi est vidée de
sa substance, mais le groupe LIOT
ne renonce pas.
- Je déposerai un amendement pour
non pas réécrire, mais pour
remettre le texte initial.
- Réintroduire l'abrogation des 64
ans par amendement.
Objectif: obtenir un vote sur
cette mesure dans l'hémicycle.
Un scénario peu probable.
La présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale s'apprête à brandir le
couperet de l'irrecevabilité
financière, au titre de l'article
40 de la Constitution.
Déterminé à maintenir la pression,
Charles de Courson n'exclut pas le
dépôt d'une nouvelle motion de
censure.
- Kathia Gilder: Claude Malhuret,
quand vous regardez ce qui s'est
passé en commission des Affaires
sociales, qu'est-ce que ça vous
inspire?
La majorité présidentielle a eu
peur du vote?
- Claude Malhuret: Quand je
regarde ça, je suis content d'être
sénateur.
Ils sont en train de transformer
l'Assemblée nationale en un
guignol.
C'est très grave.
- Kathia Gilder: C'est indigne des
élus de la République?
- Claude Malhuret: Bien sûr.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous parlez de
qui?
- Claude Malhuret: C'est La France
Insoumise, que j'appelle "La
France indigne".
Ils discréditent nos institutions.
Ils veulent la fin de la Ve
République.
Bien entendu, ils n'y arriveront
pas.
Ca fait neuf mois que ça dure.
Il y a des affrontements en
commission, dans l'hémicycle, que
tous les Français regardent.
Quand je rentre dans l'Allier,
plusieurs personnes me disent
qu'ils n'iront pas voter.
Cela porte un coup grave à nos
institutions.
Ils se tirent une balle dans le
pied.
Petit à petit, ils perdent de
l'influence.
Ils se tirent une balle dans le
pied pour les élections
législatives.
Je parle de LFI.
Ils discréditent nos institutions.
Vous l'avez dit dans le reportage,
cette loi, nous le savons depuis
le début, n'a aucune chance de
passer.
Elle est anticonstitutionnelle.
Tout cela est fait pour ennuyer le
gouvernement.
Tous ceux qui la font savent
qu'elle ne passera pas.
Ce que je voudrais dire, c'est que
vous avez cette entreprise de
démolition, de la part de
l'extrême gauche, que l'extrême
droite regarde...
A droite, vous avez des idiots
utiles.
Je suis content d'être sénateur
parce que les idiots utiles de
LIOT, je pense qu'ils devraient se
méfier.
Ce n'est jamais bon de se faire
applaudir par ses ennemis.
Au Sénat, la droite, notamment Les
Républicains, a une attitude
indigne.
- Alexandre Poussart: Il n'y a pas
une entreprise d'empêchement de la
part de la majorité présidentielle
et du gouvernement d'un vote de
l'Assemblée nationale sur cette
réforme des retraites?
Ce n'est pas le problème de cette
crise?
Ce n'est pas un problème
démocratique?
- Claude Malhuret: A partir du
moment où cette loi est
anticonstitutionnelle, pourquoi la
majorité présidentielle irait
jouer le jeu de continuer ce
théâtre des guignols, qui sera
arrêté au bout d'un certain temps
soit par le Sénat, soit par le
Conseil constitutionnel...
- Alexandre Poussart: Au-delà de
cette proposition de LIOT, il y a
la réforme des retraites.
Est-ce que le problème de cette
crise, ce n'est pas le fait qu'il
n'y ait pas eu de vote à
l'Assemblée nationale sur cette
réforme?
- Claude Malhuret: Je voulais vous
dire que toutes les lois qui ont
été adoptées par un 49.3 du temps
de Michel Rocard, par exemple,
ont été validées?
Le 49.3 a été créé par De Gaulle
pour éviter les impuissances de la
Ve République et éviter les
gouvernements qui changeaient tous
les deux mois parce qu'ils étaient
en minorité.
C'est une des forces de la Ve
République.
Tous les partis politiques et
toutes les majorités l'ont
utilisé.
- Kathia Gilder: On a observé que
la mobilisation populaire s'est
accentuée après l'utilisation du
49.3.
La cheffe du groupe La France
Insoumise appelle le 6 juin
à une nouvelle mobilisation pour
mettre la pression sur le
gouvernement.
Vous pensez que cette contestation
sur la réforme des retraites va
s'éteindre?
- Claude Malhuret: Je pense que
oui.
Je pense qu'ils ont déjà perdu.
Ils ont perdu le combat
législatif.
Ils n'ont pas tout à fait perdu
parce qu'ils ont réussi à
discréditer l'Assemblée nationale.
Ils la transforment, depuis
quelques mois, en une ZAD.
Quand je rentre chez moi, dans
l'Allier, que je discute avec les
gens de mon département, la
situation n'est pas la même qu'il
y a quelques mois.
Le vote n'a pas eu lieu, mais le
49.3 a eu lieu.
La motion de censure a eu lieu.
Il y a quand même une motion de
censure qui n'a pas été votée.
C'est un vote, ça!
Les gens que je vois, pas tous,
bien entendu, ils se disent...
Tout le monde a compris que le
système ne pouvait pas continuer.
Certains ne sont pas contents de
la solution.
Je pense que certains sont
résignés.
- Alexandre Poussart: On va passer
à un autre sujet.
On va parler des violences à
l'encontre des élus.
Après la démission du maire de
Saint-Brevin, victime de la
violence de l'extrême droite, les
sénateurs ont auditionné le préfet
de Loire-Atlantique et le
sous-préfet de Saint-Nazaire sur
l'accompagnement des maires par
l'Etat.
Cette semaine, la majorité de
droite et du centre du Sénat ont
fait des propositions pour mieux
protéger nos élus de ces
violences.
- Les explications des hauts
fonctionnaires étaient très
attendues par les sénateurs.
Deux semaines après la démission
du maire de Saint-Brevin, le
préfet de région du Pays de la
Loire et le sous-préfet de
Saint-Nazaire ont pu répliquer aux
charges de Yannick Morez.
- Quand il dit qu'il a organisé
des réunions publiques, il ment.
Il suffit de lui demander la date.
- Le préfet a tenu à réaffirmer
que l'Etat n'avait pas manqué à
ses devoirs et avait toujours
soutenu le maire.
- Nous avons accordé une attention
immédiate aux maires.
Je ne crois pas que l'Etat soit
obligé de soutenir un maire
lâchement ciblé par un incendie.
- Une fois le domicile de Yannick
Morez incendié, quel soutien
l'Etat a-t-il apporté au maire de
Saint-Brevin?
- Est-ce que vous êtes allé à
- J'ai eu le maire le jour de
l'incendie.
Je n'ai pas perçu de demandes
particulières de sa part à ce
moment-là, peut-être à tort, mais
je n'ai pas eu le réflexe de
l'appeler ensuite pour lui dire
que j'allais venir chez lui.
- L'audition des hauts
fonctionnaires n'a pas convaincu
les parlementaires, mais l'affaire
du maire de Saint-Brevin a
particulièrement touché la Chambre
haute, qui compte légiférer pour
renforcer la sécurité des élus.
- Le maire, ce n'est pas n'importe
qui, c'est l'incarnation de
l'Etat.
Il représente l'autorité.
On ne peut pas tolérer des
dilettantes avec des gens qui
portent atteinte à la République.
- Cette proposition de loi sera
examinée au début de la prochaine
session parlementaire.
- Alexandre Poussart: Est-ce que
l'Etat a tardé à protéger et à
accompagner le maire de
Saint-Brevin?
- Claude Malhuret: Je suis
incapable de répondre.
Je ne connais pas les détails de
l'affaire.
Ca a l'air très compliqué.
Je fais confiance aux conclusions
de la commission du Sénat.
- Kathia Gilder: Il faut durcir
les sanctions légales contre les
auteurs de violences contre les
élus?
- Claude Malhuret: Je l'ai demandé
dans une question au gouvernement
il y a une quinzaine de jours.
Je pense qu'il faut défendre les
élus.
Est-ce qu'ils ne sont pas assez
défendus aujourd'hui?
Il y a un certain nombre de
mécanismes et de mesures.
Si on retrouve les auteurs de
l'incendie, je pense qu'il faut
s'en souvenir.
- Kathia Gilder: Il faut durcir
les sanctions?
- Claude Malhuret: Pourquoi durcir
Je ne pense pas qu'on soit dans
une société, et je suis en
désaccord avec beaucoup de gens,
plus violente qu'avant.
Si vous consultez les historiens
sur le long terme, ils vous disent
que la société a plutôt tendance à
se pacifier.
A l'époque de mes parents, avec
les dizaines de millions de morts
des guerres mondiales ou avant,
avec la Première Guerre
mondiale...
Avant, les enfants étaient battus.
Aujourd'hui, si vous donnez une
gifle à un enfant, c'est
scandaleux.
Presque chaque famille avait un
martinet chez elle.
Je vous parle d'un temps qui n'est
pas si ancien.
Il y avait des violences
intrafamiliales.
Il y avait des violences sexistes.
Je pense que plus ça va, plus
elles font scandale.
En revanche, sur les institutions,
sur les forces de l'ordre...
La contestation des institutions,
la contestation de la démocratie
et de ceux qui la représentent me
semble être en augmentation.
Vous connaissez mon opinion
là-dessus.
L'une des raisons, c'est aussi la
montée des réseaux sociaux.
Obama a dit que les réseaux
sociaux étaient devenus une des
principales menaces pour notre
démocratie.
Moi-même, ça ne me fait rien.
Au moment des gilets jaunes, j'ai
reçu des centaines de menaces de
mort.
Je ne suis pas le seul.
Mes collègues parlementaires ont
eu leur permanence saccagée.
- Alexandre Poussart: Vous pensez
que des sanctions pénales peuvent
diminuer cette défiance?
- Claude Malhuret: Je ne pense pas
que ce soit une solution radicale
et définitive.
Mais il faut marquer le coup.
Aujourd'hui, les institutions sont
plus attaquées qu'avant, tout
comme la démocratie.
La démocratie est beaucoup plus en
danger qu'elle ne l'était en 90,
quand les régimes autoritaires se
sont effondrés.
Il faut faire réfléchir les plus
idiots, qui n'ont pas encore
compris que ça leur coûterait plus
cher...
Je pense que cette mesure marquera
le coup.
- Alexandre Poussart: On va voir
l'agenda du Parlement de la
semaine prochaine.
- Kathia Gilder: A l'Assemblée, le
7 juin, ce sera le vote solennel
de la loi de programmation
militaire qui donne plus de moyens
aux armées face aux cybermenaces.
Le 8 juin, la proposition de loi
de LIOT, dont on a parlé, pour
abroger le recul de l'âge de
départ à la retraite.
Ce sera en séance.
- Alexandre Poussart: Au Sénat, le
6 juin, ce sera l'examen du projet
de loi du ministère de la Justice,
pour un budget augmenté.
Mardi, les sénateurs ont
auditionné la ministre chargée des
professions de santé sur la fin de
vie.
C'est elle qui va porter le projet
de loi sur la fin de vie.
Jeudi 8 juin, au Sénat, la
commission d'enquête parle du
réseau social TikTok et de sa
stratégie d'influence.
On va parler de ce sujet, Claude
Malhuret.
Raphaël Glucksmann a été
auditionné et il revenait sur la
décision de la Commission
européenne.
- On a reçu une note
confidentielle.
Je ne peux pas la partager.
Elle explique les risques.
Elle n'a pas été communiquée
publiquement.
Il n'y a pas de volonté
d'expliquer publiquement pourquoi
on cible TikTok.
C'est une mesure de précaution.
C'est fondé sur l'idée de risque,
sur des preuves d'espionnage
avérées.
Ces risques sont conséquents, et
le fait de ne pas les partager, à
mon avis, est problématique
politiquement, démocratiquement,
et relève d'une politique
européenne qui est, depuis
longtemps, de ne pas antagoniser
la Chine.
- Alexandre Poussart: Est-ce que
la Commission européenne est trop
tendre?
- Claude Malhuret: Je dirais
qu'elle est prudente.
Elle a quand même un mérite.
Personne n'a encore rien fait, et
c'est la première institution à
faire quelque chose.
Elle interdit l'application à tous
ses fonctionnaires.
Elle n'a pas le droit de
l'interdire dans tous les pays
européens.
Elle fait sa partie du travail.
Dans les jours qui ont suivi,
pratiquement tous les pays
européens ont pris la même
décision.
Raphaël Glucksmann a raison.
Pourquoi elle ne va pas plus loin?
Parce qu'elle ne peut pas.
Elle est prudente.
Elle n'explique pas publiquement
parce qu'elle sait la raison pour
laquelle elle est interdite.
Il y a un transfert massif de
données des utilisateurs de TikTok
dans tous les pays occidentaux en
Chine.
En Chine, les sociétés qui
possèdent TikTok sont liées au
gouvernement chinois.
Il y a un risque d'espionnage
majeur.
Pourquoi la Commission européenne
ne le dit pas?
Elle ne veut pas envenimer les
rapports avec Pékin.
Mais la réalité, tout le monde la
connaît.
C'est un transfert de données
réel.
- Kathia Gilder: Certains pays ont
interdit l'usage de TikTok dans
leur parlement.
Il faudrait le faire à l'Assemblée
et au Sénat?
- Claude Malhuret: J'attends la
fin de la commission d'enquête
pour voir les recommandations que
l'on fera.
Dans un premier temps, je crois
que le fait de l'interdire aux
fonctionnaires de l'Etat, aux
fonctionnaires en général, c'est
important.
Si on me demandait un conseil, si
les sénateurs me demandaient un
conseil, ce serait de ne pas
télécharger cette application.
Evidemment, il faut toujours peser
la balance dans un pays
démocratique entre les précautions
à prendre et les dangers.
Il y a aussi la liberté
d'expression.
Je vous rappelle l'affaire de
Russia Today.
Ce sont des organes de
désinformation de Poutine.
On m'a dit de ne pas m'y attaquer.
Le jour où la Russie a envahi
l'Ukraine, on a enfin compris de
quoi il s'agissait.
Je crois qu'il faut être plus
ferme.
- Alexandre Poussart: Jeudi
prochain, vous allez auditionner
les dirigeants de TikTok.
Quelles questions allez-vous leur
poser?
- Claude Malhuret: J'ai beaucoup
de questions.
- Kathia Gilder: Par exemple,
l'ex-directeur des affaires
publiques de TikTok.
- Claude Malhuret: Il y a trois
sujets dans cette commission
d'enquête.
Premièrement, le problème des
transferts de données et la
mainmise des Chinois sur ces
données.
Deuxièmement, il y a l'algorithme
extrêmement addictif.
Les parents nous disent de faire
quelque chose.
Leurs enfants passent des nuits
dessus.
C'est un algorithme beaucoup plus
addictif que celui de Facebook.
Il y a des problèmes de
développement psychologique des
enfants.
Troisièmement, c'est le sujet sur
l'ascension de la désinformation
potentielle.
- Kathia Gilder: On va en
reparler.
- Claude Malhuret: D'autant plus
que l'audition est publique.
Vous pourrez l'écouter.
- Kathia Gilder: On va dire un mot
d'une autre commission d'enquête,
celle de l'Assemblée nationale sur
les ingérences étrangères.
Le rapport révélé par Mediapart
accuse le Front National d'avoir
eu des liens avec le pouvoir
russe.
- Il y a un parti politique en
France qui s'est avéré être
beaucoup plus que d'autres un
relais assez affirmé, assez
constant, d'éléments de discours,
de prises de position du discours
du Kremlin.
- C'est le Rassemblement National?
- Oui.
- Certains ont conclu que nous
aurions des liens avec la Russie.
Il y aurait des rapports
accablants.
Mais rien ne permet d'établir nos
liens avec la Russie.
- Kathia Gilder: Question simple:
pour vous, le RN est une courroie
de transmission du Kremlin?
- Claude Malhuret: C'est évident.
C'est évident depuis longtemps.
Je l'ai exprimé à plusieurs
reprises au Sénat dans des
questions au gouvernement, dans
des débats.
C'est une évidence pour un certain
nombre de membres, comme Thierry
Mariani, qui font aujourd'hui
l'objet d'enquêtes judiciaires...
On essaie de faire la lumière sur
le fait qu'ils seraient en lien ou
non avec la Russie.
Depuis des années, le RN est une
courroie de transmission de
Poutine.
- Kathia Gilder: Elle a eu raison,
Elisabeth Borne, de dire que le RN
était l'héritier du pétainisme?
- Claude Malhuret: Il y a, dans
les fondateurs du Front National,
non seulement des collabos et des
pétainistes, mais aussi des gens
qui étaient à la légion des
volontaires français.
Je voudrais quand même faire une
remarque.
Il y a un parti qui est un relais
d'influence, mais il y a aussi
LFI.
- Alexandre Poussart: C'est la fin
de cette émission.
Merci d'être venu cette semaine.